that cooler weather is good news for the
more than one thousand firefighters
battling the largest fire in los angeles
city history it is one of at least 74
wildfires burning across the west jamie
yukis is at a destroyed home in los
angeles jamie good morning good morning
the mandatory evacuations have been
lifted and the 210 freeway is back open
but take a look at this this is one of
three homes that was destroyed in this
fire and firefighters say this is a
reminder as to why people need to take
extra precautions with the fire only 30
percent contained
even with temperatures dropping and the
weather beginning to cooperate with
emergency crews the largest wildfire in
los angeles city history continues to
grow visually can see we've turned a
corner but this is not over with winds
this strong anything can still happen
over the weekend the latuna fire tore
through thousands of acres advancing
toward the city of los angeles and
destroying at least three homes
including linda sherdell's within 15
minutes the house was overtaken there's
nothing standing no walls everything is
just ash craig boleson's family home in
sunland burned to the ground he was able
to save his father carrying him by his
wheelchair
we left things we had packed up and
because we thought you know we have
minutes
we had 90 seconds temperatures over the
last few days have approached and broken
the 100 degree mark leaving people
living near the fire line scrambling to
save their homes any way they can
you never know when it's out it'll look
like it's out and it could flare up at
any second so it's not it's not over
until it's really over we can handle
everything we have to we don't have an
option we cannot fail so we are
continually planning preparing and
training
the extreme heat is over the high
temperatures today will be in the low to
mid 80s and firefighters hope that helps
them get a handle on this more than 7
thousand now acre brush fire but we have
seen some hot spots pop up and there is
concern that the wind could come back up
that could carry fire to new spots
the wrath of mother nature jaime yucas
thank you